acte de moscou notre correspondante
verhaeghe hoffman verra bonjour alors on
vient de le dire la situation est plutôt
alarmante à moscou elle s'est dégradée
ces derniers jours bonjour doha oui
effectivement vaccination obligatoire
contre le coup vite pour le secteur des
services moscou et sa région prenne des
mesures drastiques afin d'arrêter la
hausse importante des contaminations
près de 14000 car de convives en voici
donc presque 6000 à moscou ont été
enregistrés ces dernières vingt quatre
heures
le maire de la capitale sergueï
sobianine a qualifié la situation dans
la ville de gramat tic je vous propose
d'écouter l'évolution de la situation
liée aux covit 19 reste dramatique plus
de douze mille personnes se trouvent
dans les hôpitaux dans divers états de
gravité
le taux d'infection a déjà atteint celui
des périodes de pic de l'année dernière
à cause de la situation épidémiologique
extrêmement grave
le médecin sanitaire en chef pour la
ville de moscou a adopté aujourd'hui une
résolution relative à la vaccination
obligatoire des employés du secteur des
services
environ 20 millions de personnes
habitent dans l'agglomération de moscou
moscou se trouve au carrefour de toutes
les routes
ce sont nous qui faisons face aux coups
les plus durs de la pandémie
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
en premier lieu besoin d'une protection
sérieuse contre cette maladie dangereuse
et pour empêcher la mort de milliers de
moscovites helena andré 20 médecins
sanitaire en chef de la ville de moscou
à son tour chargé les chefs d'entreprise
de faire vacciner 60 % des employés
d'ici le 15 juillet pour la première
injection d'ici le 15 août pour la
deuxième
écoutez la situation épidémiologique
lyall un fix you coronavirus dans la
ville de moscou est considérée comme
mauvaise depuis le 6 juin 2021
le taux de nouveaux cas enregistrés
augmente de manière plus intense
l'augmentation journalière est temps de
11% à cette date et allant jusqu'à 20%
les jours suivants la situation liée à
l'infection au cours aux navires us à
moscou se détériore lors de l'analyse de
l'incidence il a été constaté que les
individus en âge de travailler de 18 à
60 ans soit 60 % de la population
étaient plus susceptibles d'attraper la
maladie il ya quelques jours le maire
de moscou avaient signé un décret
prévoyant une semaine chômé du 12 au 20
juin une décision ayant pour but
d'arrêter la hausse du nombre de cas et
de préserver la vie des gens sergueï
sobianine a également pris la décision
de fermer les aires de jeux pour les
enfants dans les parcs et dans les
centres commerciaux jusqu'au 20 juin et
a appelé les employeurs à privilégier le
télétravail pour ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés contre le coc ville de verre à
d'autres malades en direct de moscou
remercie pour toutes ces précisions